E
TOLD ONE PERSON IN THAT VEHICLE
LATER DIED FROM HEAT EXHAUSTION.
JOINING ME NOW IS LIEUTENANT
CHRISTOPHER OLIVAREZ OF THE
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
YOU KNOW, THE SHEER NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE ARE SO TROUBLING COMING
OVER THE BORDER, BUT ANOTHER
HUGE CONCERN IS THE AMOUNT OF
DRUGS POURING OVER THE BORDER AS
WELL.
WE HAVE SOME NUMBERS WE NEED TO
PUT UP ON THE SCREEN.
RECENTLY, OFFICIALS HAVE
RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF POUNDS OF
COCAINE AND FENTANYL WITH A
STREET VALUE OF $2.2 MILLION.
COCAINE, HEROIN, MARIJUANA, AND
METH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
IT IS NOT LIKE WE DIDN'T HAVE A
DRUG PROBLEM BEFORE.
>> RIGHT.
YOU ARE CORRECT.
WE HAVE ALWAYS HAVE THESE ISSUES
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT NOT
TO THE EXTENT WE ARE SEEING NOW.
THAT IS WHY GOVERNOR ABBOTT
LAUNCHED THIS BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENT FAILURES TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
CRACKDOWN ON CRIMINAL ACTIVITY,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, TRYING TO
PUT A STOP TO THESE HIGH SPEED
DANGEROUS PURSUITS.
THEY ARE VERY BOLD, AND RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE SEEING THEM DO
THINGS THEY HAVE NEVER DONE
BEFORE AS FAR AS THE EXTENT OF
THE RECKLESS DRIVING.
THEY PUT THESE IMMIGRANTS IN
DANGER.
AND WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT TO
INCREASE BECAUSE OF WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW.
>> Anita: NO DOUBT.
IT ONLY MAKES YOUR JOB EVEN
HARDER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE COVER
OF "THE NEW YORK POST."
THIS IS SHOWING BORDER PATROL
AGENTS OR PATROL AGENTS WERE
RESORTING TO CLOGGING UP A
20-FOOT GAP IN THE WALL WITH
TIRES AND CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS
LEFT BY FORMER FEDERAL
CONTRACTORS.
I MEAN, THIS SEEMS RIDICULOUS.
>> IT IS.
THAT SHOULDN'T BE TAKING PLACE
RIGHT NOW.
THEY SHOULD BE A MEASURE IN
PLACE.
IT SHOULD BE CONTINUE TO BE
CONSTRUCTED.
BECAUSE OF THE INITIATIVES THAT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT LAUNCHED, WE
HAVE BEGUN TO CONSTRUCT BORDER
FENCING BY USING THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE NOW ENFORCING -- WE ARE
NOW MAKING ARRESTS ON CRIMINAL
TRESPASSERS AND CRIMINAL
MISCHIEF.
WE ARE TAKING THOSE MEASURES,
STEPPING IN, CRACKING DOWN
BECAUSE THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IS FAILING TO DO
THAT.
>> Anita: YEAH, AND YOU ARE
SAYING THAT THOUGH WALL IS
HELPING YOUR SITUATION?
>> WELL, RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE
PLENTY OF RESOURCES THAT ARE
BEING PROVIDED BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF SUPPORT FROM
GOVERNOR ABBOTT, THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
WE ARE PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER ALONG WITH
THE TEXAS MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN WITH
THE RESOURCES, THE CAPABILITIES
THAT WE HAVE TO ENFORCE THESE
LAWS BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT DOING ITS
JOB.
BORDER PATROL IS STRETCHED THIN.
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN.
>> Anita: OF COURSE YOU ARE
ONLY DOING WHAT YOU CAN.
ANOTHER MIGRANT CARAVAN IS NOW
HEADING TO THE U.S. BORDER FROM
THE CITY OF KAPPA CHULA, FILLED
WITH WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO BE DONE
ABOUT HOW MUCH OUR BORDER PATROL
AGENTS LIKE YOU, WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED MORE ON THE GROUND.
>> REAL QUICK, THE SITUATION IS
OUT OF CONTROL.
AND THUS THAN ADMINISTRATION
STEPS IN, PUT SOME POLICIES IN
PLACE, WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE THESE HISTORIC NUMBERS.
RIGHT NOW, NOTHING IS BEING DONE
ON THEIR PART, BUT THE STATE OF
TEXAS IS DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE AND
KEEP THE NATION SAFE.
>> Anita: THEY SAY DON'T MESS